His darkness that lets him do what Heroes cannot
the battle you're meant to fight is upon us
there's no one on this planet that
can stop me before a world of Heroes
and villains
one power ruled it all Black Adam
he's been asleep for 5 000 years
I got him we're here to negotiate your
peaceful surrender I'm not peaceful
nor do I surrender his powers are not
a gift but a curse born out of rage
you have two choices you can be the
destroyer of this world or you can be
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
will be my new Black Adam trailer video
and talking about Superman coming back to
the dceu so a lot of you probably saw it
in your feeds the Superman is coming back
in the Black Adam movie and in The Flash
movie and they're finally actually developing
a Man of Steel 2 movie so I'll explain what's
going on I'll talk about the Superman
stuff first then I'll talk about the New
Black Adam footage everybody just wants to know
what's going on with brand new Superman stuff
all right if you're brand new to the channel of
course I'll be doing a bunch of videos for Black
Adam and for the Return of Superman hearing about
the return of Henry Cavill Superman just makes me
nostalgic for all those comics when I was a
little kid the death and Return of Superman
they kind of did a version of that with the
Justice League Snyder cut and him coming back
in the black suit like he did in the comics but
the big news you probably saw in your feeds is
they did confirm that there was a Henry Cavill
Superman post-credits scene in the Black Adam
movie and it was tied to Amanda Waller trying
to get everybody to stop Black Adam in the way
that the movie positions him relative to the
rest of the dceu because obviously the Justice
Society is really big during the movie but you
also wonder what's happening with the Justice
League at that point like why does Amanda Waller
go to the Justice Society first before just going
straight to the Justice League because Black Adam
is so powerful and they basically confirmed a lot
of my early suspicions just based on black
Adam's comic book Arc Sarah shahi's Adriana
Tomas character frees him after he's been trapped
for 5000 years by the wizard Shazam he finds out
condak has been co-opted in present day it's been
taken over by a lot of different forces inner gang
is a big villain during the film it sounds like
but they're also trying to bring back the demon
sabach who you see during the trail that's that
Reg character there who is way worse than Black
Adam in Amanda Waller sensing the threat of Black
Adam just because he could go either way he could
go darker he could actually help them tries to
pull a classic Suicide Squad move on him bring
him in and help them get rid of sabak and that's
where you have all these scenes of Dr Fate trying
to tell him like look this would go one of two
ways you could help destroy the world because
you have so much power or two you could help us
also stop sabak from completely destroying the
planet and it sounds like Adriana Tomas and
her son are going to be a big part of that
they actually confirmed that this is her son her
brother is this character here and even though it
seems like she's really down with him being super
dark like oh his Darkness lets him do what Heroes
cannot there's the other trailer footage where
she takes Black Adam to task for trying to teach
her son violence like don't teach him to be so
hardcore so it sounds like she and her son become
a surrogate for his dead wife and his dead son
and they soften him up a little bit and he helps
them out but by the end of the film he basically
retakes conduct like he does in the comics and
rules over with an iron fist but Amanda Waller
then basically tells them that kondok is now
his prison like do not leave conduct stay there
do whatever you want inside your own country but
the minute that you try to conquer other parts of
the world we will send more hardcore people after
you and she's talking about the Justice League and
Superman in Black Adam basically calls her on her
bullcrap like what are you gonna do to stop me
what could you possibly do nobody on this planet
is powerful enough to stop me there's no one on
this planet that can stop me and then reportedly
we see Superman show up in that post-credit scene
where he's the person who's strong enough on the
planet to stop him and supposedly he has a couple
lines in the post-credits scene where he basically
just tells him what you expect him to say like
it's been a while since we've seen someone so
powerful on planet Earth that's made us so nervous
we should have a conversation so it's basically
like Superman just coming to talk to Black Adam to
find out what he's all about reportedly they are
going to use the John Williams Superman theme even
Zack Snyder said that factoring the Man of Steel
movie he wanted to use more of the classic
John Williams theme but the studio was like
no no even though Han Zimmer's Superman music
totally slaps you just can't do a new Superman
movie without like a little bit of that classic
John Williams theme it's just so awesome foreign
reportedly it's the beginning of Henry Cavill
coming back as Superman in a much bigger way
and he'll do it again like something similar to
this during The Flash movie I don't know what
his scenes during The Flash movie are going to be
like like we have a bunch of Ben Affleck's Batman
coming back in that and obviously we have all the
Michael Keaton Batman Multiverse stuff happening
in the movie it just sounds like they added some
Henry Cavill Superman stuff to it as well like
this whole deal with Henry Cavill coming back to
Superman is relatively recent I believe and he
and Warner Brothers just worked out whatever their
problems were they got over all that stuff I don't
know if he's also coming back during a cameo
during the Aquaman 2 movie or during Shazam 2
but long term reportedly they are developing Man
of Steel too and it'll be like a man of Tomorrow
movie which is basically what everybody thought
that it was going to be years and years ago I did
a whole bunch of Man of Steel 2 videos a couple
years ago back when they were still hyping up the
Justice League Snyder cup before that actually
come out because of all the big company changes
the regime changes at Warner Brothers reportedly
it just took these past couple of years for Henry
Cavill and Warner Brothers proper to work out
their differences for him actually coming back
in Superman so if you heard reports about them
pulling a shazam movie post-credits scene where
like you see his costume but you don't see his
face supposedly they worked out those differences
and now it will actually be visible Henry Cavill
who will have some dialogue during this movie
which I think is the best possible scenario like
even if they started working on Man of Steel 2
right now it would take them at least two two
and a half years to get that movie out but in
the meantime there are so many upcoming DC movies
that you can put him in that he would work really
well in and I think this just supports the idea
that long term they are going to develop a Black
Adam versus the Justice League movie The Rock had
been talking about that for a while and he just
posted that funny Instagram video where he kind
of confirmed that Henry Cavill is coming back he
is the most powerful and Unstoppable force on
this planet on this planet he plays a bunch of
the soundtrack in the background so I had to cut
down the video to him actually just making the
Superman reference so the funny thing about all
this Superman coming back Henry Cavill coming back
is that you really do have to thank the rock for
being the one to make this happen because he's so
powerful relative to his own franchise's Black
Adam character that he can actually do that at
Warner Brothers like look Grease the wheels let's
get rid of all this bureaucracy work out your deal
with Henry Cavill because I want to do a movie
with him typically when it comes to actors coming
back as characters like even Ben Affleck coming
back during The Flash movie A lot of that has
to do with what the director wants to do with the
characters in one of Warner Brothers big things is
that they wanted to let the directors do whatever
they wanted to do which is why you had all these
issues with films not being totally connected
the way that you wanted them to be connected but
on the flip side that also gave them the power
to bring back whoever they wanted to bring back
it sounds like now the big difference with this
new regime is that they're just way more heavy on
doing more core Superman stuff than the previous
regime was like bring back whoever you want to
bring back and yes we totally will do a bunch
of Superman stuff and make a Superman Sequel and
it is about time it's been almost 10 years but if
you remember that original plan for all the movies
that Warner Brothers had planned to do when they
first announced that Justice League was eventually
going to happen when Zack Snyder was first hired
to do Man of Steel in Batman v Superman originally
Batman v Superman was going to be Man of Steel 2
and I think what wound up happening is that the
studio kind of freaked in the Man of Steel movie
didn't make quite as much money as they wanted to
so they're like okay put Batman in Man of Steel
too and we'll just put Batman in the title of the
movie so it turned from Man of Steel 2 into Batman
v Superman and I think the reason why they didn't
just go straight to that after the first Justice
League movie is because of obvious reasons because
of the response after it was released in theaters
thankfully they worked out all their differences
and he is back as Superman I feel like he could be
Superman for like the next 10 15 years if he wants
to Hugh Jackman and Patrick Stewart basically just
shattered the record for the amount of time that
an actor has played a particular character like
they just announced in the Deadpool 3 teaser video
that Hugh Jackman is coming back as Wolverine
everybody freaked out I made a bunch of videos
about it it's gonna be awesome so Hugh Jackman
will have played that character for over 20 years
when he comes back and also Patrick Stewart same
idea he came back and Doctor Strange Multiverse of
Madness as a version of Professor X so he's been
playing that character for also over 20 years
so unless Patrick Stewart also comes back as a
version of Professor X in Deadpool 3 and he might
actually do that Hugh Jackman will be the record
holder in the Marvel Universe but Michael Keaton
will actually be the new record holder when he
comes back from his original Batman 1989 women get
more footage about what's going on with Michael
Keaton's Batman also do a bunch of videos about
that too but everybody post all your reactions in
the comments below what do you actually want them
to do with Superman before Man of Steel 2 and what
do you actually want them to do in Man of Steel
too there's so many huge Superman characters that
they haven't done in the DCEU yet that they could
do for his movies DCEU Brainiac is probably the
biggest one you also have the whole idea you that
they haven't really done a Superman versus dceu
Lex Luthor movie yet even though he's been in
some of his previous films my Full House of the
Dragon episode 8 video will post next while you
wait for everything click here for my Deadpool
3 Wolverine trailer video so happy that he's
back and click here for my house of the Dragon
episode 8 video I'll update the link as soon as I
post that thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!